[Music]
uh it's my pleasure here to share our
journey on building out linkedin's ji
platform uh my name is sh ad manager of
J
Foundation uh and try it one more time
cool uh in today's talk I'd like to
First share our journey on building out
this platform especially on why we're
building it how we build it and what
we're building it after that we will
talk about uh some thought process on
why this platform is critical for
today's agent
word um hopefully after that you agree
with me this is critical component in
your component uh uh in your company and
you also want to build this team I want
to share some tips on how to build such
a team how to H for such a team towards
the end we will share some K takeways
and the Lessons
Learned before we dive into this
application uh platform journey I think
it's important to first talk about the
ji product experience because that's
essentially what our platform is
supporting for back in 2023 LinkedIn
launched the four first the formal GI
feature called collaborative articles
this is a kind straightforward uh GI
feature if we are thinking in this
standard because it's a very simple
prompt in string out type of
application uh we leverage chat GPT uh I
mean we leverage GPT 4 model uh to
create the long content uh articles on
the platform and they invite our members
to comment on it at this stage our team
helped to build some key component
behind the scene including the gateway
to centralize the access to the model uh
some Pyon notebook for the prom
engineering uh but at this time we
actually have two different Tex Stacks
uh to serve the uh experience in the
online phase we use Java and in the back
end we use Python uh we wouldn't call
this as a platform at this
time very soon we realize there are some
limitation for this simple approach
especially it lacks the capability to
inject our reach data into the product
experience then in the mid 2023 we
started to develop the second generation
of the ji product uh internally we
called a co-pilot or coach here we're
showing one popular such experience on
LinkedIn right now uh basically it looks
at uh your profile and the job
description and then uh use uh some rag
process to give you personalized uh
recommendation on if you are good fit to
the
job at this time we started to build uh
some platform capability uh specifically
in the center of our platform we build
the uh python SDK on top of the popular
uh lunching framework to orchestrate
ourm calls and it also provide the key
value to integrate with our large scale
infrastructure uh in this SDK so our
developers can easily assemble
application we started to unify the text
stack at this stage because we realize
it's really costly to transfer the
python prompt into the Java world not to
mention the arrow during this process we
started to invest on the prompt
management or promp source of Truth this
is a subm module at this stage uh to
help developers to version their prompt
and to provide some structure around
their meta
prompt uh the most important piece I'd
like to call out here is conversational
memory uh this is uh infrastructure to
help to keep track of the llm
interactions and retrieval content and
then inject those content into the final
product it will help us to build this
kind of conversational uh bot
now uh zooming to this year uh actually
in the last year uh we launched our
first ever uh real multiagent system
called uh LinkedIn H assistant uh this
is uh multi-agent systems to help our
recruiters to do their work uh
efficiently especially it automate
several teers task normally recuiter
need to do manually like um post the job
um and the valuate hundreds of
candidates then reach out to
them our platform also start to involve
into the agent platform uh from the
framework side we extend the support of
the Python SDK into a more large skilled
um distributed agent orchestration layer
it will handle the distributed agent
execution and also handled the more
complicated scenarios like retry logic
and the traffic shift uh for folks who
build agent uh I think you probably know
the skills or apis are one key aspect of
the agent because we expect uh this
agent to perform some action one
investment we did at this uh time is
around the skill registry basically we
have a set of tools uh to help our
developers to publish their API into
this centralized skill registry this
skill
can handle the skill Discovery problem
skill invocation problem so in your
application it's actually very easy to
call the API to perform some
task another key component uh we invest
at this stage is on the memory in
addition to the conversational memory we
extend uh it capability into the
experential memory essentially it's a
memory storage to uh extract and analyze
and infer the tectural Knowledge from
the interaction between the agent and
our user we also organize this memory
into different layers including the
um working memory long-term memory
Collective memories uh this can help our
agent to be aware of the surrounding
content uh lastly at this uh time we
also realize the operability is super
important because agent uh one key
aspect to Define agent is autonomous
right uh because agent can decide what
API they can call what L LM they need to
call so it's actually very hard to
predict Its Behavior so we started to
invest on the
operability uh particularly we build our
in-house Solution on top of the hotel to
keep track very low level granularity of
the uh telary data so we can use this
data to replay the uh agent call and we
also add a actual layer of the analytics
on top of it so we can use that to guide
the future optimization of our agent
systems let's put together all the
components we build for this platform uh
we can classify them into four layers
basically including the orchestration
prom engineering tools and skills
invocation content and the memory uh
management uh of course that's not
everything in the LinkedIn ji ecosystem
uh in addition we have our sister teams
to build out the modeling layer like
fine tune the open source models
responsible AI layers to make sure the
agent is behave according to our policy
and standard and also the uh AI platform
or machine learning infrastructure team
to host those
models the key value preparation for
this uh ji platform is actually to uh be
the unified inter interace for this
complex
ecosystem so our developers don't need
to necessarily understand all those
individual box when they build uh their
application instead they can leverage
our platform to quickly access to this
entire ecosystem uh for example uh in
our SDK the developer can just switch
one parameter in the one L of the code
to switch from the open a model to our
onr model model of course they still
need to do the prompt engineering but
that reduce a lot of the complexity on
the infrastructure integration
face uh last but the most importantly is
because of this is centralized platform
uh it provide a place to enforce the
best practice and governance so we can
make sure our developers are building
the applications efficiently but also
responsibly as you can see from our
journey we actually start to build this
uh platform piece by piece and then this
platform start to emerge if we take one
step back and think uh do we really need
this platform at this time especially
there are lots of uh uh uh vendor
product on this space shall we buy it
build it and why do we need to buy it or
build it uh here are some
thoughts um the short answer is yes the
reason behind it is uh we feel like J is
totally different new AI systems
compared to the traditional AI systems
so in the traditional AI systems there's
a clear cut off between the uh AI model
optimization phase and the model serving
phase so AI engineers and product
Engineers can operate in two different
tax stack uh they usually don't uh need
to uh work on the same code base but in
the ji systems what we're seeing is this
line between the optimization phase and
the serving phase disappear basically
everyone is a engineer who can optimize
the overall system performance this
actually created the new challenge of
the tooling and the best practice in the
company essentially we think this ji
systems or agent systems is a compound
AI system here we borrow the definition
from Berkeley AI research lab a compound
AI system can be defined as a system
which tackles AI tasks using multiple
interacting components including
multiple cost to model retrievers or
external tools as you can see this is
actually skill across AI engineer and
product engineer and I believe this uh J
app platform is trying to bridge this
Gap to summarize uh we believe this
platform is critical for your success
mainly because it can Bridge the skill
gaps between those two group
Engineers okay let's say if you want to
build this uh platform in your company
and how to hire it is a frequent
question uh I heard um I basically look
into uh my great engineering team and uh
extract all the key qualifiers from
those top engineers and uh I put all the
qualifications here uh the ideal
candidate in this team is a strong
software engineer uh who can build
infrastructure integration they have a
good developer uh PM skills to design
the interface uh ideally they have the
AI and the data science background to
understand the latest techniques they
are the people who can learn from the
latest techniques but at the same time
they are hands
on unfortunately it's really hard to
guide those candidates if you get them
uh it's probably worth more than
unicorn realistically we are making
multiple tradeoff in the Hing uh here
are some principle uh we follow and it's
actually working pretty well on to share
here in terms of the core skills uh we
usually prioritize the stronger software
engineering skills over the AI expertise
this might be controversial but uh uh uh
we can discuss if you're
interested second is instead of hiring
for experience or degrees we hire for
the potential because this field is
involving so fast most of the experience
might be
outdated in case you won't be able to
find a single engineer with all the
qualifications we're showing here uh the
way we are solving this problem is to
hire a diversified team so so for
example uh in our team we have some full
stack software Engineers we have data
scientist we have ai engineers and data
Engineers we also have a fresh grads uh
from the top research University and
also uh some people from the startup
background and then we put them together
uh into the project what we've seen is
based on those collaboration those
strong Engineers start to pick up new
skills in the project and very soon they
started to grow into these ideal
candidates uh lastly is uh want to
emphasize is uh the critical thinking uh
one constant topic uh in our team
meeting is uh no matter what we're
building right now it will be outdated
within a year or even less than six
month so we consistently evaluate the
latest open source package talking with
vendors and deprecate our solution more
proactively
cool let's talk about the say some uh K
takeways uh especially on the tax stack
choice if possible we strongly recommend
python we started with Java and python
uh there are some back and forth of the
debate internally but finally we pick
Python and I think that's a right choice
especially most research and open source
uh are in this space based on our
experience it's also scalable
in terms of the uh key components you
want to build in this platform the first
one is prompt source of Truth prompt in
some way is like a traditional model
parameters you want to have a really
robust systems to Version Control your
prompt this is really really critical
for the operational stability you don't
want accidentally addit your promp in
production and uh see some really S
effect second key component is on the
memory I think in today's uh me Mee uh I
mean today's talk someone already talked
about it memory is a really key
component to inject your Rich data into
the agent experience lastly in the agent
era uh one key new component we are
building is on the uplifting our apis
into skills which can be called from the
agent easily so you can uh build some
surrounding tooling and infrastructure
to support this
need all right let's talk about how to
uh skill this solution and got get it
adopted uh from our experience instead
of trying to build this full-fledged the
platform at the beginning try to solve
immediate need for example we started
with a simple python library to support
orchestration then we started to grow
into all the components we're seeing
here second is uh focus on the
infrastructure and the scalable solution
and Linkedin we actually have a pretty
good success story by leveraging our uh
messaging infrastructure uh to be as a
memory layer uh is both cost efficient
and scalable last day is uh focus on the
developer experience by the end of the
day this platform is trying to help
developer to be as productive as
possible their adoption is a key for the
success if you can design this platform
please focus on uh how to align your
technology with their existing uh
workflow so it will ease adoption and uh
be more
successful uh we actually have lots of
lowlevel details on the technical side
uh if you are interested please check
out our engineering blog post on
LinkedIn by Cake s and
myself uh with that uh thank you for
your attention and uh if you are having
more questions question happy to answer
that after the talk thank you
[Music]